so
let's start the next part of
part two make this tutorial
okay uh
thanks for coming back so hopefully i
didn't scare you or bore you or maybe
now you're sitting here regretting like
maybe you skipped the last session
you're regretting oh no
why did i come in it just seems like i
shouldn't have been here well you're
stuck here sorry but thanks for coming
back um
okay so
i feel like i'm seeing mostly
faces that were here if you were in here
we talked about different paradigms of
learning and now we just started talking
about
uh sort of the min max theorem in zero
sum games
uh
so let me
you went through this slide so this is
probably a good place to start again um
kind of i i also got a question during
the the break so i think um for those of
you who haven't seen this before maybe
another
place to pay attention to is that
what is it that each player is doing
so we talked about zero-sum games and
each player is picking a distribution
over actions
so if i go back to the model of the game
i have this game matrix row player
column players
each row and each column are
these we call them actions or pure
strategies and
essentially each player has to now pick
a distribution over its rows or columns
so that's an important aspect of talking
about this min max and max men and
especially if you want them to be
equivalent
as we said in a celebrated
monuments mid-max serum
so
we ended the last
talk
by just kind of looking at this my
theorem and asking first of all what is
it saying and when is it true
and i said that
at the very least
we don't
okay
this slide doesn't tell you anything
about um
infinite matrices or whether or not for
infinite matrices this min max holds
that's something we're going to talk
about uh briefly
uh in a little bit but before we do that
um it's good to
really think about why should even the
min max serum hold even for finite gates
so not for these really weird corner
cases but for the
most natural small playing games that
you can think about
why should it hold
and i'm going to try to tell you a
little bit about this
although you have probably seen
something like this even maybe in the
previous tutorials or in the courses
that you've taken
so there's two direction in the midmax
theorem and you were just talking it's
always
takes a second to realize which one is
the easy direction
one is this fund which
essentially says that whoever goes
second
is better at doing their job than if
they had to go first
kind of like the way to think about it
is that the person going second
um
knows what their uh
can can curate the response
to whatever the other player had done
so now their response is very very well
curated and because of that they do a
better job so if the maximize maximizer
goes second
uh he can make the value larger than if
he were to go first and the same if the
minimizer goes second you can make the
value smaller
than if he had to go first
so this part of the min max theorem is
true just
by understanding what you're giving up
um
curating your response to something very
specific rather than trying to cover all
of your bases if you are going to go
first
now the difficult part is realizing that
the reverse direction hopes
and
the reverse direction if you want to
think about it is that you're
giving up the chance of going second
and essentially you're almost like as if
you're committing to something
not knowing what would have been their
responses
so in itself has something very robust
built into it that you don't know what
kind of responses you would have seen
but you still want to do well
and this is where the connection sort of
to online learning
comes through
in a beautiful paper and observation
uh
it's
it's been shown that essentially online
learnability
and min max are both about interactions
with an adversary
and at least for finite games one way
that you could have proved the reverse
direction of this
claim
is to use a no regret algorithm
or
or two no regret algorithms
let me talk about the version where
essentially what you're doing is you
take one player player one
we are telling them that they need to be
a no regret algorithm
what that means is that the
probability distributions are producing
these pt's at every time step they're
producing something new
and if i look
at the end of time and i want to know if
they regretted not having committed to
some p from the beginning
that p
they had very
little regret this regret would have
gone to zero the spanish movement so
this is what i'm asking player one to do
and then for player two there are many
different versions of this you can also
ask them to be no regret but i'd
actually rather ask them to be something
that's much simpler which is the best
responder so they can even see the pt at
this current time step and they're
always best responding to it
now i'm not saying that i'm changing the
min max theorem to now hold in a
repeated way
no i'm saying that i can get this
repeated interaction to prove the min
max 0.
and how i would do it is that
i'm not going to show you the proof
is to say that actually
literally this this kind of the regret
here is not having known what to commit
to
and it's very similar to saying that if
you switch your min and max
your regret there would have come here
and as long as you have a no regret
algorithm
you're going to
get this inequality to hold
at the tighter and tighter
inequality until your regret is exactly
zero and then this is going to hold the
way you want it
what this is saying is that
essentially the average if i run this
game
infinitely long
the average strategies that will come
out of this are in fact min max
strategies there are the type of
strategies that you could have committed
to
not having cared about what people are
going to do
okay
this is a high level idea um kos has
talked a lot more about actually what
happens to i think pt and qt itself but
we are ignoring all of that we're just
proving them in next year
so
yeah
so is this uh
they're very connected so it's
definitely a duality proof uh
minoxidil and
duality they're all highly highly
connected to each other
and no regret learning
um blackwell approachability bunch of
others also are different ways of sort
of addressing the same concepts
so they're all highly limited
okay
um
so
if i write such a thing for you the next
thing you're gonna ask is
well
it seems like online learning or online
learnability um
has some role to play when it comes to
the definition of an equilibrium
what is that draw
is it that anytime you can have an
online algorithm
you prove that a min max theorem exists
just because you can ask one of the
players to play an online algorithm
that's the question we're going to
answer briefly
um
by talking about the role of little fun
dimension and role of online learning in
particular here because remember we want
to talk about adversaries
so the very first question is is online
learnability a sufficient condition for
minmax theorem to hold
and the reason you might believe this
is because
oops
because
essentially the only thing here i did
was to say that let player one play an
online algorithm
and especially an online algorithm
for deciding these pgs
so it feels like what i told you
essentially is um
saying that
any online algorithm would have been
good enough anything that makes an
online algorithm work
is good enough
so one question is
in the previous slide uh using your
landlord ability to show the min max you
are using you do jensen somewhere like
to just like to
you know for what you have on the bottom
left there you have a sum of losses
eventually you want to put the sound
inside the laws
so you will use jensen so this proof
uses a convex concavity of linear
so
i
though the question is yeah do you need
this multilinguality or complexity uh or
are you
okay so
i mean the way i define the next theorem
for finite for for a game for finite
games is that the expectation itself is
linearizing this problem
but there's another way i would have i
could have talked about uh midnight's
theorem
which would have been about sort of pure
maybe i don't want to call it pure
strategy but about points it's like x
and y
not uh these are not necessarily
representative of um
appointment like probability
distributions and in that case then what
that l of those
would have been would have been
important
and um there is there is an assumption
that is convex in one and concave in
another that's usually the general form
of minox theorem written for these
arbitrary spaces
so i thought i simplified this already
for you guys so we are in the linear
world dealing with the expectations
um
and sort of so this is already
constructed
so i'm talking about the min max
in games
so you want to talk about the mean max
in general games uh
zero sum games
zero sum games but potentially infinity
sounds
just understand that means that if it
has a infinite size in every round i
submit the
infinite
uh
i think this is your question which is
one of the subtleties i was going to
mention
um
i've asked you to give me a call will be
distribution
for instantly many rules
and how would you represent that that's
that's itself a little bit problematic
let me not answer this yet because there
are some other subtleties that i need to
tell you and then i'll give you one
solution
statement of the solution that fixes
both your issue and other issues
but that that is that is an issue
um
um
let me give one other comment about this
um which is that
i could have i'm interested in this
value rather than the actual strategies
so i could have replaced this max with a
suit and then with that
in fact a lot of the things i'm going to
talk about
from now on
especially when you start entering the
internet games are about the soup hint
rather than maximum
and that by itself should tell you
something because maybe you have a
sequence of quality distributions that
have a certain property and
um they're sort of easier to talk about
than just probably distribution
okay
so
there are already really good questions
coming then
but
i want to put my own question forward as
well
which is that
is online learning sufficient and
there are a couple of reasons that it's
not
one is that
games and game theory in general
require the mixed strategies to be
probability distributions over the
actions
so
it's important that there's a policy
distribution over the rows if i'm
playing
rock paper scissors with you it's
important that what you do is also rock
paper scissors
if i enter a game and i think that i'm
playing rock paper scissors and you
bring a tank
maybe you'll win but that wasn't the
sort of the contract we made
so
that's actually not true for the way i
define learning
for online learning i actually allowed
you to do whatever you want okay
if you thought that a tank was necessary
you could have used it and
there was nothing to stop you from that
this is a solo point um
let's go back this is this is the little
the exact slide that i had for online
learning before
wait
i'm confused sorry
what do you mean that we do not know the
actions that we will play how then i
play
uh let me let me actually give you an
example here
um for games it's important you know the
action set and you play only on that no
you cannot invent another action
for learning you can invent
hypothesis which refers to actions
and here is so this this is the slide
and i want you to focus on three aspects
of this and hopefully it's clear with
the pr i feel like the
then this light uh
the colors are a little bit different
okay so you have to focus here here
right here
okay the first two places you're
focusing
um
i defined the function class h that was
going to be what we competed
but i never forced you to play any
function from that class
specifically i use ft rather than hg to
emphasize the fact that this doesn't
have to come from your class this is
what i mean that you could have invented
any function here you want
it wasn't one of the rows in what i
offered you
now
there are these proper learning
algorithms proper online learning and we
call them proper if fd had to belong to
this language
so really the question that you have to
answer
if you want online learning to be
sufficient from an xml
is
whether
the there are online learning algorithms
that first are proper
and second
our characterized the regret is
characterized by or upper bounded just
by little some dimension again
not my size of the class not by some
other combinatorial dimension but by the
little summation
why do we care about proper now
i there was a
question earlier uh last uh talk
which said what what what about what is
this random thing we were talking about
how your ft could be at random it could
have been chosen at random
so now if you have a proper algorithm
and you chose ft at random that's
exactly the same as having chosen a row
or a distribution over your rows where
the rows refer to those hypotheses
so now an online algorithm at every step
is literally picking a probability
distribution over its rows
okay
the way that i defined the
and now i've changed the symbol of my
algorithm i still i didn't have time to
check the simpler standard if one of you
knows tell me how do i have to check it
later
um the algorithm that i told you it kind
of inductively does a little dimension
calculation
uh
i think that's what i had in the last
one and just like hallucinated simple
and it's
simple it's more standard okay um
the
the simple optimal algorithm
they maybe defined it at least uh it
wasn't obvious that it was proper
why wasn't obvious that it was proper
first of all it didn't really choose a
hypothesis
if i go back here
what it was choosing
um
was how to label something
this y hat this was the label that it
was suggesting and
there's no guarantee that there is a
hypothesis
that would have matched this for every x
at least it doesn't come with that
guarantee and because of that maybe it's
not obvious here but because of that
this is written in a different language
at least there is no obvious reason that
soa should be
a
proper algorithm
so
but the nice thing about this and i had
promised you that i will have some quite
recent results
is that that's been resolved and the
standard optimal algorithm
can be implemented as a proper learning
algorithm
with finite support and in fact we kind
of know what its support is as a
function of this vc dimension and the
little dimension of the class
um
so what that is saying is that
in fact the simple optimal algorithm
you could think about that at every time
it's using majority vote of
only a few of these
rows majority votes meaning that it's
going to have it in its support
and
that allows us to now say that
because that simple optimal algorithm
was proper
and its regret was still defined by just
like something like almost little
dimension divided by t square root of it
now finiteness of nils and dimension is
going to be sufficient for my min max
serum to hold
i still have no proof of it being
necessary
but it's sufficient because what i can
do is to take this algorithm
and plug it into
the first player's algorithm and then
the second player was going to best
respond
and that's going to give me the min
axiory i'm holding
is it possible that it's necessary
is it possible that it's necessary we
actually know the characterization it's
the next slide so i will talk about that
in a few minutes any questions about
this before i talk about necessity
what does this find support me here like
this is an algorithm and what is the
finite support here well what i mean is
that the policy distribution that it's
using at every time step so the game has
infinitely many rows but actually it
only the policy distribution has support
only on finite dimension
maybe i will repeat what you said but
that would be verified that i understood
correctly so the algorithm what we'll do
is that we will have all the hypothesis
that is the distributions that we would
play
we will follow the simple optimal
algorithm just to play for this round
and we know that just in the
limit uh
we will get the
min max
theorem because they regret the
boulevards did they get correctly um
it's important that i i'm not sure if
you mentioned the plugin in so the this
is uh
this is an important aspect of it so you
can just plug it in without uh also
making sure that the adversary is best
responding yeah right and then
you plug in that algorithm that is
proper any algorithm that's proper and
only depends on the lucian dimension
it's regret here
and
that soa is one example
and he will respond with a hypoth with a
distribution or uh
the player too
never needs to actually respond with a
because it's player two
you can come up with uh deterministic
actions as a response right so the
player twos is not very important just
the fact that it's not uh it's not
passive it has to actually do something
here the pt is a distribution and it has
finite support
that's the only point
okay
further questions
thank you for here
okay so samina asked and i mean is the
next question you should ask uh
is thousand dimension is necessary
i think this is really interesting
which is that surprisingly it's not
um here i have a class of infinite
little sun dimension
it's the same class we talked before
this example is actually from uh
communication with steve hanneke uh
where
you're uh you have these intervals from
an integer to twice the integer
and we talked about the fact that this
has a infinitely less one dimension
but actually the min max and maximum
value here are about zero
i didn't have time to draw this as much
but uh
kind of like uh
at a high level
what you would have done
here
is let's say as the learner
what you need to do is to decide a
distribution over
these funky intervals
and
and what you want is let's say that
you're trying to minimize
that
one
so
one way to think about it is that
doesn't matter and the adversary has
some distribution over the instances
and instances are here
you can always sort of cut this
somewhere and put your interval here
so that there is very little um
probability distribution in this corner
and you can move this farther and
further and farther
or
or it doesn't matter have to be farther
you could just move it anywhere
to make sure that it's capturing uh
a small amount of the distribution
so that's kind of why what you would do
if you were the learner
um
what you do if you were an ad you were
the adversary is uh
also try to have i didn't work this out
exactly
but you would sort of pick a
distribution
that
any
um
that in any interval of a to 2a
it has
it's it's sort of yeah okay so it's
density is uh kind of like falling in
these intervals a to two a
so that uh you're not going to be uh
giving a lot of room to the learner to
actually capture this
i didn't work this out so i have to work
this out but i think this is kind of the
overall idea
of why you could show that both the min
max and max men are going in the limit
the soup infant and soup is actually
going to be zero
because you can
make sure that you do not essentially
capture any of the
distribution in the active part of your
interval um either way
so
that's an example of why infinite little
sun dimension is not necessary and you
can work this out
uh at home
but
i wanted to highlight
an interesting aspect of this which i
promised last i
actually gave you a pointer in the last
uh
last talk
which is
how come it's not sufficient like if i
think about that infinite tree that i
made
it should be quite easy to show that
anytime i have this infinite tree
like i grew a tree down to infinity i
could have continued growing it
i shouldn't have min max serum because a
very similar idea that we had which was
kind of you you know what the adversary
has to do to make sure that the
um there's a gap between the average
request there's a gap between max and
max man
then
intuition here is that um
there's a difference between
growing a tree to infinity and having
infinitely large trees
so to capture that actually this paper
uh comes up with a different notion
of uh
uh of complexity
and that notion is going to characterize
it it's definitely related to those
dimensions but not the same and it's
going to characterize when min max and
maximum hold for zero one uh valued
games
so what is this
this claim is that
let me take any game matrix this is
infinitely large game matrix
if i can have a sub game of it where the
stock game the
rows can be
sort of rearranged so that it's
triangular
if i can do that
and i can create this for an infinitely
large sub matrix that has this property
then
the min max theorem is not going to hold
and that's the only condition that will
make min max theorem not holding
so existence of an infinite sub game
that is triangular
here is
the interesting part
i mean actually all of it is interesting
but here's the subtle part
as we discussed there's two ways to make
little sun dimension infinite
one was to take a single tree and grow
it to infinity
and the other was to keep coming up with
bigger and bigger and bigger trees
note that the bigger and bigger and
bigger trees
don't exactly follow this type of sub
game
because this is a subgame that you have
to you the fact that it's a sub game
like every sub game of it is um has this
triangular behavior is something that
means that you should have been able to
grow it to infinity
the but there are classes that little
dimension is infinite not because of the
subgame but because there are
there are larger and larger and larger
and larger little dimension trees
so this this notion of uh
um
sorry that
the infinite sub game
is exactly trying to differentiate these
two from each other
and one we have them in max theorem
holding and the other we don't have them
in maximum holder
think of it as saying that
in one there is always a sub game
with the
rows that we call the triangular for all
d and the other there's actually an
infinite b
i think that that can
be thought about it is the same but let
me just say that this is not going to be
the same as low sum dimension
um
there is this other dimension
called the threshold dimension which is
essentially this but it doesn't have it
it can again be infinite in two
different ways
uh it doesn't have to be like a
something
and uh what you're saying i think would
be the equivalent the analogous to that
and what we know is that
that dimension and little dimension
are written
um
double exponentially within each other
so if one is the important thing is that
if one is finite the other is minus but
um the actual numerical thing doesn't
translate
yeah
if i
look about random matrices
it's a question
if i have a random matrix where its
entry
would be with probably one half
plus one
and the other minus one do we know
if
a zero or one it doesn't matter do we
know if a random infinite
matrix will have a
malicious triangular matrix
okay i have to think about this but this
seems like question you can answer so
that like stochastic like it's just like
a process
it feels like it should if you are
infinitely growing it you should be able
to have it in a second but i might be
wrong
it's not something i can answer
but uh this is a question you need to
answer like the better one of it some
content uh
i don't know if it has to be i guess
when you're talking about random
matrices uh i guess you want to save it
some probability that holding or not
right yeah it feels like it's sure
because you're allowing it to grow it
like you're allowing the image to grow
alternately so you should be able to
you should be able to show that it's
something
counting should allow you to do that but
again i'm not going to claim that but i
think you can do it
okay questions about this
is there any hope to extend this for
games that are not 001
maybe it's next time no it's not the
next slide but i will mention that
actually has done some work on that uh
you don't know a characterization we
don't want to
but before i get to that um
we saw a lot of different results and i
want to take an opportunity to actually
think about them beyond the mathematical
thing
what we have noticed is that at the very
minimum we've noticed is that
learnability is very sensitive to
adversarial assumptions
and to the particular notion of
adversarial assumption because we know
that zero sum and online learning are
very similar to each other but there's
still a difference in what is
characterizing them
and of course offline and online are
quite different from each other and
there is a huge gap between the two
so at the very least what we know is
that this is we need to really think
deeply about our adversarial assumptions
but i think one other thing that i would
take from the last two
rows especially is that
it feels like the
particular definition of adversary
is uh
really important in the sense that some
of these results especially the little
stone dimension
appears to be brittle because even if
you don't change the adversary it's so
adversary but you're changing sort of
the context of what you're thinking
about you change the characterization
and in the next part of this talk i'm
going to dig deeper here and try to open
this online learning and really look at
how brittle is this
and are we sort of closer if we try to
avoid those brittle cases are we closer
to offline learning or are we somewhere
else
so that's a quick takeaway
the other thing is that there are a
bunch of things i did not mention this
is a very interesting area and that's
real value functions and real value like
games
for the first two for uh
adversarial um
for for stochastic and adversarial they
actually have a pretty good
understanding of all of that
uh there are several different ways of
characterizing them so there is um
there's radar marker complexity and
sequential atomic complexity there is
to the dimension as a counterpart of
each dimension there are a bunch of
other things there's fat chattering
there's a lot of different things
but these two essentially are what
characterize uh those processes um so we
at least understand them really well
for min max uh
there are sufficient conditions as i
said that question has worked on
with a lot of students no i don't know
he's coming later in the semester
uh and uh
but it's not a necessary
um type of it's not necessary so it's
still not characterization it's much
harder to think about characterization
for real values functions especially
because the margin conditions start
mattering but it's through something
that looks like sequential patch other
um that's it for this part
other questions before i move on to this
kind of looking at these brittle
examples a little bit more
okay
so
here is uh
as i told you this kind of the huge gap
between offline and online and then also
the differences between online admin max
really
i encourage us to really think more
deeply about the differences between
these two are we actually in one world
or the other both of them seem sort of
um maybe one is very idealistic the
other is like super pessimistic way of
uh
looking at
reality so can we have a slightly more
realist point of view
and
this is something that algorithm design
has done for decades now
in the sense that we are we love talking
about worst case adversaries we love
talking about sort of average case and
then everything is beautiful
but we also want to talk about what
happens in between those like do these
models actually nicely transition to one
another or not
and that's what's called smooth analysis
one of the ways to do this is at least
smooth analysis framework
um
a little bit of an overview um
beautiful very impactful work
an idea from uh swimming and tang about
that started with sort of simplex and
kind of understanding oh we know simplex
doesn't do well for worst-case
adversaries but does it do well if i
were to perturb my adversary a little
bit
so smooth analysis the idea is that the
adversary chooses an instance and then
the nature perturbs it slightly like
adds a gaussian noise to it
and then the goal is for instance that
either an expectation or with high
probability over these perturbations
you want to
give a good and a good performance
guarantee
and this has been repeated in
many different applications the modern
perspective on these gaussian
perturbations are that maybe it's not
gaussian necessarily
actually the adversary is choosing
the adversary is choosing a distribution
over instances and this distribution has
to be sufficiently anti-concentrated
there was a question earlier about
thinking about distributions in the
worst case and we were saying that they
could be sort of focused on one thing
and here we are saying that they had to
be sort of dispersed and
anti-concentrated
and
this is a really useful framework when
we suspect that there is something the
worst case instances are brittle
and ideally what we want to be able to
get is that essentially we're going to
get the same performance guarantees as
an average case as in when things came
from a distribution
but for the case of adversaries that
have been smoothed
so what does this look like
um
let me skip this since we are a bit
short of time um
what does a smooth analysis perspective
on online learning actually look like
well we're going to start with the model
we had which was i have a world i have a
learner and i have an adversary
but now my adversary is not an adversary
and it's not the world it's a
combination of the two
what it's doing is that at every time
it's picking a distribution
and that distribution uh he could have
picked it knowing everything about the
algorithm and the history
again if i allow the distribution to be
super focused on one point this is just
the adversarial view of the world
but i'm going to change this by saying
that the smooth the sigma smooth
distribution is a distribution that
cannot focus on any one point in fact
its max density has to be something like
one over sigma times the uniform density
over the domain
something like this uh a uniform upper
bound
on the max density that you can provide
and we are doing it with comparison to
the uniform distribution you could do it
many different ways actually
and then what you're asking is again the
same thing you know what happens to the
regret
in fact in the this is the more modern
perspective of what i was saying is the
gaussian perspective which is that the
adversary would have chosen an instance
and then the instance would have
some gaussian noise would have perturbed
it okay
and in this language this was uh both of
them were actually introduced by
siddharth and rocklin tewari in 2011.
so
i like this formulation because it's not
about a specific noise model it's much
more general
and what you're hoping is that we are
going to get vanishing regret
and
sort of uh get it but not something that
depends on little some dimension anymore
right you want to avoid that the
dependence on little some dimension
which was really large even as soon as i
put a threshold in it would have jumped
to infinity pro more
so
to recall i can actually write the worst
case and sort of the best case in terms
of two different languages of amount of
smoothness
so the worst case is if i have no
smoothness at all
and a very good case it's not the
offline it's actually a special type of
offline it's the uniform case where the
distribution itself was uniform
uh refers to sigma being one
and we know that
uh this is the higher characterization
with the little dimension this is an
upper one actually
only the only claim here is that it's an
upper bound
and we know that sort of the way that we
look at the first row is to interpret it
as an impossibility result because
thresholds are so common in machine
learning that's how we distinguish
between good and bad zero one allowed
not allowed
and essentially little some dimension
jumps to infinity whenever we do that
so
what we want is to
avoid this situation
and
a nice result uh here
with collaboration in collaboration with
timmer of course my student abhishek
abhijay shetty is uh
looking at what the regret bound here
would look like
for uh
for smooth analysis
so what we've shown is that even in
presence of an adaptive adversary that
takes the sigma you know smooth
distribution based on what's happened in
the past
you can still get regret that looks so
much more like the offline learning
setting it's characterized only by vc
dimension
and not by little so dimension
of course it's going to have a limit a
very tiny dependence logarithmic on the
size of the noise this is something that
you cannot avoid because when the noise
is zero you should go back to the low
some dimension
so this is the overview of what i'm
going to talk about are there any
questions about the setup
another question
um
yeah so if the sigma is one so there's a
bunch of things that i haven't covered
here
single one over t is probably fine you
don't want it to be one over two to the
t for sure
um
i don't want it to be tiny i think sigma
one of our team might be actually okay
uh
uh i'm not sure if one of her tea is
okay or not so there's some log of
things that i haven't put here
so um
but i think one of our tea is fine
so since i'm talking about the
dimensions it's funnier value but
everything i say falls in the real
values better suit the dimensions
so it's actually it is um
the neat thing here is that we actually
really do a reduction to the offline
setup so whatever would have worked out
for that class in the optimum setting on
the uniform distribution is actually the
thing that comes in here
okay
so
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
this uh
and i want to just build some intuition
here so what are the challenges because
this is going to build more intuition
about the challenges of the adversarial
setting and also why smoothness helps
question yeah yeah
about the bomb
just as a mathematical curiosity could
someone
prove
that
when
when i have the limit that sigma goes to
to zero
then
the vc dimension
[Music]
would become
the
a
little
dimension no so it's okay so you're
asking a good question but the vc
dimension little sun dimension is not
the right way to frame it
these dimensions underneath the
dimension are only about hypothesis
classes they have nothing built into
them
so
we do have
this characterization
actually tells us something about
little dimension
in terms of vc dimension and the size of
the size of the domain
okay
and
this i mean it comes out of this
characterization it wasn't known before
and this log of one over sigma you can
think about it as the effective size of
the domain
um
another way to say this is that you
could have asked this question about um
something like rather marker complexity
and
if you want to talk about that we can
talk about it offline as some some
ongoing work that i have in my group
okay
so i wanted to start kind of thinking
about why did the stochastic case work
here and then what's failing
so the reason there's like like one
reason that the stochastic setting is
working
is that uh i have
something defined as a net and net is an
approximation of my hypothesis class and
it's a finite approximation of it so i
replace my hypothesis class which is
potentially infinite with a finite
hypothesis class where each hypothesis
has a proxy so
like this grid is the proxies of my
hypothesis
and i want something about this net it
has to be a good net and goodness is one
that
it doesn't have a lot of weight between
and like not many points fall between
any
uh hypothesis and its proxy so that sort
of measured over the distribution
the a function is close to its proxy
that's what you want from a net and
that's something you can easily get
and it's kind of for this distribution
looks like this you know
a hypothesis
uh here its proxy is going to be there
and sort of if there is less than
epsilon in that total thing
that function is going to be close to
this hypothesis measured over a
distribution
and the reason sort of the offline
setting works is that um
not only in expectation this is small
what that means is that
because i have iid assumption on the
adversary the world is
throwing things at random into this
distribution
i have this anti-concentration property
about each of these little bits in my
net
what this means is that iid-ness is not
allowing the adversary or the world to
put too many points here
so they are close to each other both in
expectation and in reality after things
has been realized
so the thing that makes the adversary to
be really powerful is literally not
having this anti-concentration the fact
that an adversary can always focus
arbitrarily in one area
because it can correlate the future not
trivially with the past
okay
so that's what we are trying to avoid
when we don't have iid assumption a more
powerful adversary would definitely be
able to correlate
the question we are wondering here is
that of course
i have this like sigma smooth assumption
none of my distributions are focused in
one place so i can make a net that is
reasonable
but because the adversary is adaptive
because this is a long term strategy
maybe the adversary in long term can
still sort of focus in one area
so is it that correlations across time
are actually messing up my
anti-concentration properties that's
literally the question we have to answer
which is that how do we preserve
anti-concentration from one step to the
next to the next to the next over t
times steps
even when those distributions themselves
were adapted to each other
and here the challenge is that the
literal correlations across time the
fact that a new distribution
was chosen after i realized
drew some instances from the previous so
they are highly correlated still
so
we actually introduced a toolbox here
that can be used not just in online
learning but can be used in talking
about any adaptive adversary in smooth
analysis
and i'm going to just talk a little bit
about that toolbox the most important
tool in there is a type of probability
coupling
and policy coupling is just a fancy way
of talking about the joint distribution
distribution
but a joint distribution
that has
sorry
but a joint distribution
that has some nice property embedded
into it
between the sort of each draw of x and z
um
the idea that we are going to use is
that i have an adversary that's in
smooth analysis that's generating these
instances can i couple this adversary
with a fully stochastic distribution
because if i could couple it
and i have some nice
sort of
behavior between this coupling
essentially maybe i can replace an
adversary with a fully stochastic world
and be sure that that's doable
all you have to do is to actually
increase your set of points that you're
going to generate so for any adaptive
sequence of t distributions that are
sigma smooth
there is a coupling between
the adaptive adversary adversary
sequence
and the uniform distribution
in the sense that i can
with high probability
he draws from my adaptive adversary is
going to be included in the set of t
times k draws
for uh
from a uniform distribution where k is
about one over sigma okay
so the nice property of a coupling here
is really this monotonicity
is the fact that by i'm producing a
little bit more random variables but i'm
making sure that my this set of random
variables includes all the ones that
would have been really produced
why is this a good property
it's good properties because first of
all i'm coupling it with uniform
distribution
uniform distribution is like the
model distribution for
anti-concentration it's not concentrated
it's like the least concentrated that
you can figure to find out
so if
the uniform distribution is not
concentrated
and
my real set of variables is a subset of
it then this couldn't have been too
concentrated either at a slightly
different time time scale but
by coupling it to the uniform
distribution i'm borrowing those
properties of a uniform distribution
so this allows me to say that if that
area between h and its h proxy didn't
include too many x's from the adversary
it doesn't because it doesn't include
too many z's from the uniform
distribution
and essentially all i've done is that
um i have replaced an adaptive smooth
adversary
in my analysis not an actual algorithm
and actually like but in my analysis
with a fully stochastic adversary on a
slightly different time scale
now
how does this work together just we're
gonna see this at very high level this
is going to allow us to do the following
i choose my net
the net is usually defined over a
distribution and i don't know what
distribution so i'm going to just define
it based on uniform which was sort of my
basis of defining what a smooth
distribution looks like
then what i have to use algorithmically
is i'm just going to run an algorithm
for the worst case regret like for the
worst case uh instances
on the net only okay i'm going to ignore
all the other hypothesis
so this is the algorithm
now
as i said we chose this from the uniform
distribution because if you choose it
from the uniform distribution
the fact that it's uh you're working
with sigma smooth distribution actually
makes it nice in expectation you don't
have a lot of weight there
and in expectation you can show that for
any for a fixed um sort of cell here for
a fixed h and h proxy
um you should you have a pretty low
expectation of having points in there
that's just a sigma smoothness working
within that
the thing you want however is something
not just about the expectation of a
single cell
but an expectation of everything
in fact this includes a switch between a
min and max but another way to think
about it is that
i want to
talk about what is my approximation
error which is kind of like the max
number of points in any of those little
holes
and i can think about this i can just
ignore those random variables and
introduce the uniform random variables
using my coupling because that set
inclusion is something that works nicely
with this summation here
and once i do this i'm back in the world
with uniform distribution
in the uniform distribution
things work out nicely with just vc
dimension alone and not the lows in the
metro
that's it
so here what we really see is that there
is a toolbox that we can replace t
interactions with an adaptive smooth an
adversary
with that of a uniform
with slightly longer time scale but of a
uniform world
and the nice thing is that it allows us
to borrow not just analysis but also
algorithms from the stochastic world if
we choose to
this is a very general model i gave you
an example from online learning to
highlight especially the brittleness of
online learning characterization
but it works in general for many other
settings and i think the way you want to
think about it is that
you are getting the ideal results which
is to get essentially the same
performance as in the offline setting as
you would in the online setting with
just a little bit of smoothing
or
essentially this coupling that i talked
about
can get rid of the worst part of an ad
worse part of an adversary
and bring you back to something that
looks a lot more like an offline world
or a lot a lot more like his fully
successful world
this gives us a recipe you can actually
apply this recipe to generally many
different problems you could think about
it as
what is the recipe you just take your
problem that you want uh it has an
offline version and online version
you solve the problem for the uniform
distribution it's usually the easiest
thing you can do
once you do that you isolate where you
use anti-concentration those are usually
things that respond well to set
inclusion
once you identify them in all of those
steps you apply a coupling and replace
um your sort of adaptively generated
random variables with uniformly
generated random variables slightly more
often
and then you bring it back once you do
that you're done you'll come back and
continue the rest of the analysis
and you continue the rest of the
analysis
by sort of having accounted for the
uniform distribution on a slightly
different time scale
and as an example not only this works in
online learning we've also applied it to
a bunch of other online problems or
problems that aren't necessarily online
but use the same min max idea to solve
the problem statement so
online problems like for example online
learning online discrepancy data-driven
algorithm design
but there are problems like differential
privacy that really use min max
formulation
to their advantage and we can sort of
apply the same ideas there as well
so
kind of the wrap of the first part of it
today last hour and now
is that we saw that learnability is very
sensitive to
the exact adversarial assumptions we are
making
um but it's that sensitivity is also
partly brittle
and to really identify that brittleness
instead of using worst case analysis we
use beyond worst case analysis
okay
that's it for today as i promised you
i was
very much wishfully thinking that i'm
going to finish this part today which i
didn't
so the plan for tomorrow is i will talk
about the computational aspect and i'll
start here
but i'll talk about it very briefly
because otherwise we're not going to get
to the other stuff
and then we'll talk about uh
more generally non-zero sum games i'm
more generally thinking about general
sort of strategic behavior and then
later collaboration
and here
it's like we have three minutes or
something right okay i'm here for more
questions if you have and yes questions
okay uh yeah
it's just very nice this is a smooth
analysis it's really enjoyable
just
our curiosity is it
it seems very sensitive to the
uniform
is that the correct
interpretation that you really need
so the way we wrote it was for uniform
because it just made that's the way that
historically people define
modern perspective on smooth analysis
you can essentially repeat this as long
as you have a reference distribution
so if i fix the reference distribution
and
minus some really weird corner cases if
i fix the reference distribution
um then
and tell you that you're allowed only
distributions that are multiplicatively
at most this much larger
everywhere point wise than this
reference distribution then you can
repeat everything i said and you can
just change the coupling so that you're
coupling it with the reference
distribution that they're calling
what i'm trying to understand is that
you might say that well i'm going to use
the uniform distribution but there might
be better
distribution that you can use so that
your regret
becomes lower
so
it's a little bit unfair because
i could have done the following i could
have said that
so
uniform
is
reasonable at the same time the sense
that let me say that i made an
assumption by saying that actually this
distribution is only supported on five
items
now all of a sudden i went from
something that this littlest one
dimension was crazy high to something
that's described on two to the five many
different functions
so
it's
it's a bit unfair to take advantage of
smooth analysis in that way and that's
why it's usually
referred to a distribution that it
itself has a reasonable performance but
it's usually you don't make um lower
bound assumptions you just make higher
upper bound assumptions that are
either uniform or welcome or something
that's kind of more reasonable because
otherwise
there are tricks that you can just like
make your problem just too easy and you
don't want to abuse that
other questions
i'm curious what you would say you know
your next
section are you gonna recover tomorrow
or uh i'm gonna cover tomorrow so i had
planned the next section to actually be
relatively short
um
i was not going to change the model so
for those of you time back uh
i'm going to
i'm going to tell you a little bit more
um about
a bunch of things that are about the
computational and algorithmic aspects of
still online learning and the next
um not not just a graphic setting and
kind of like what you're going to talk
about is
uh first of all what are the algorithms
and i'm going to give you a very brief
statement of these because i don't want
to get into it and other people have
covered much of these
um
and sort of
one example of a combinatorial structure
that allows for efficient computation
and then i'll tell you a couple of open
problems
let me tell you some of the open
problems right now so i don't have to
tell them tomorrow
one open problem here is that i talked
about smooth analysis it's a version of
online learning but a little bit better
than worst case
i told you that we can always borrow
algorithms from the offline case
sometimes the algorithms that you're
borrowing from the offline case aren't
efficient for example the algorithm that
i just gave you with that algorithm
running on the net
is really inefficient the net is
exponentially sized
so
how do you actually design an algorithm
that
uses the fact that your adversary is
better than worst case but also
computationally tries to use toolboxes
that were developed for offline
optimization not two boxes that were
developed for online optimization
that's a general open problem
for online learning in particular
another
type of open problem because if i
tell you enough maybe i don't have to do
this tomorrow
is um
sort of thanks costas you gave me the
permission
yeah i'll take five minutes
i just wanted to ask a question about
the previous life okay
oh this is just uh
just i know but i thought
so
you talk about adaptive adversary versus
a stochastic adversary
so there's two ways to think about this
the result i gave you for probabilities
for adoptive adversaries
so that adaptivity that coupling
is is coupling an adaptive sequence with
something that's non-adaptive so that's
essentially saying that even in smooth
analysis you can ignore oblivious
adversaries
and
we actually before we came up with this
coupling we treated adaptive oblivious
adversaries separately because adaptive
versus were just too difficult
and
you can get actually similar results so
i think it really talks about this the
strength of the adaptive adversity
results rather than obvious adversities
being a special effect
um but for this purpose we can
essentially ignore them
um
while i'm not going to abuse the time
i um
have to show you a little bit here
because we talked about some
characterizations of
statistical characterizations of when
can i learn in the offline setting when
can i learn an online setting when does
min max serum hold
and now you can also ask them
computationally
when can i have a computationally
efficient algorithm to achieve of online
learning
and
maybe perhaps to also find
something that's approximately close to
a mid max
equilibrium
and uh
there we don't have a characterization
here there are some results for very
specifically structured uh settings uh
so if you have like a linear function in
small dimensions uh
the cities and costas have a result
about if sort of the maybe the rows are
large but there's few columns
um in general we need some assumptions
because there is an interesting result
by halton and korean that says that
even if i gave you an algorithm for
offline optimization just for
minimization for example or just for
maximization you can't do them in max
efficiently
and not only they say it for online
learning but their lower bound is
interesting in the sense that it also
applies to actually min max
in a game
and the thing that i'm going to maybe if
i have time just uh just show is that
there's a different dimension there's
still another characterization but it's
a bigger way of thinking about it
where it's still about the game matrix
and
how
how expressive the game matrix is
and uh
that is going to be at least the best
known result we know in terms of getting
efficient online algorithms
and what that looks like is saying that
i take a game matrix it's not about the
size of the game matrix it's about the
number of rows that i need to include in
my in some collection so that every two
row looks different
so
if this is very small um
of course if sort of y was small this
would have been small you just include
all of your uh your columns
but even if your y is large sometimes
you can come up with a very few columns
that essentially distinguish between any
two rows
and if you have that you can get
algorithms out of that kind of a
structure
and
i'm not gonna go into the any of this
detail in fact
i just wanted to show this because maybe
tomorrow i'll come back and use this
structure and still skip this section so
i don't have to
talk too much about computation
there is a lot of stuff beyond this
tutorial as well
yeah i just wanted to
maybe show some uh sorry some references
that i thought
i don't want people to miss her
um
and these are references that since i'm
skipping this section they're also
interesting some of them are by actually
people who are here in the semester as
well
about sort of how to not just think
about statistical stuff but also the
computational aspect
and that's it thank you for the extra
otherwise hopefully i'll see you guys
tomorrow afternoon
sorry